we can start chairman okay thank you
so i welcome everybody to today's second
cabinet meeting of january
second cabinet meeting of the year both
those are participating and those who
are watching on the live stream
uh if members have technical
difficulties during the meeting please
contact the democratic services officer
on call who would attempt to assist you
on call today is casey brewer her number
is 577046
and it will also be at the top of the
chat thread for members if you need it
for those of you who are watching by the
council's youtube stream please follow
the instructions below the video
if there are any issues with the live
feed i'd ask participants
when you're not speaking please mutual
microphone this minimizes background
noise and will help everyone listening
into the proceedings microphones must
only be on if the participant has been
granted permission to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking is
finished
please note that we'll be following the
usual cabinet protocols in which other
members of the council
usually only speak once on each item
everyone present please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
they're not used to make or receive
calls while the meeting is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
the meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public it will also be
recorded
and subsequently made available on the
internet can i ask members of the
cabinet to confirm that they're present
in the meeting when i read out their
name
i'll also ask for the attendance of
those counsellors who are participating
in order to speak under council
procedure rule 20.1 separately
uh councillor whitehead present
councillor album yes here chair
councillor duckworth
here and councillor yates prison chair
thank you now at the moment the only
counselor i've got who's asked to speak
under council provider 20.1 is
councillor pugh are you here councillor
pugh
yes president chair thank you are there
any other members who want to speak
under council procedure 20.1 tonight
doesn't seem so okay thank you so there
are no apologies for absence to
any do any members of the cabinet have
interest to declaring the items of
business on the agenda this evening
all right thank you i'm not seeing
anything so we'll take that as a no
uh the minutes of the previous meeting
uh the
cabinets asked to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
meeting on the 14th of january a copy of
which is attached to the agenda pack
um i'll propose the minutes do i have a
seconder second
secondly by councillor whitehead thank
you and if i hear any objection i'll
take these as approved
sorry check and i interject you um you
were not at the meeting so it would
require those where the meeting to
to propose fair enough
night at the meeting please
thank you
so i have to go back to this again so
who's proposing sorry i'll propose
my counselor that will consecrated by
councillor whitehead that is a very good
point charles thank you for appointing
that
i must admit i'd forgotten that wasn't
it amazing
okay we move on to item four which is
capital works program 51 57 high street
margate
and that is councillor duckworth please
so a cabinet is being asked to agree to
permit the expenditure of the allocated
budgets for the agreed capital project
to renovate 51-57 high street market
to give delegated authority to the
director of regeneration to negotiate
and agree the contract documents and to
give delegated authority to the director
of law and democracy in consultation
with the director of regeneration
to sign the contract documents and any
other necessary documents to give effect
to this decision
the council has received a grant payment
of 750 000 pounds from the ministry of
housing communities and local government
for a capital project to commence
immediately
51 to 57 high street market former
martin spencer site was
identified due to it being in the
council's ownership
and being in a key high street location
the recommendation in this report is for
a key decision to approve to commit
and spend 750 000 pounds of external
funding to deliver this capital
renovation project for 51-57 high street
markets the projects will include a
replacement roof and scaffolding
and soft strip out including safe
removal of asbestos and services
the project is externally funded by the
ministry of housing communities and
local government
and is required to be delivered within
the set criteria and restrictions of the
town's fund programme
this follows a recent decision to
include the 750
000 funding to the council's capital
works program
for 2021 22 and forward plan
an application for listed building
consent for the replacement of the roof
was granted on the 21st of january 2021
this was required due to the facade on
the subtle square
side of the buildings being grade two
listed
the buildings involved are included in a
joint venture with homes england
the works will be subject to formal
approving approval
being received through the joint venture
permitting the capital works in
accordance with the terms and conditions
within the agreement
the capital works will be procured in
line with the council's open invitation
to tender route
led by procurement and officers are
working hard to deliver the project in a
timely manner
this project will enable the vision for
the building to be more clearly defined
in line with any repurposing of high
street and town centre
it is proposed that the building could
form part of a portfolio of assets in a
new creative land trust
that is proposed within the margate town
build town investment plan
submitted to the government on the 11th
of december 2020
the proposals within the investment plan
form part of the discussion with the
joint venture partners
this capital project fits strategically
with the council's corporate priorities
and values
by supporting inward investment
promoting sustainability and growth of
local enterprise these works aim to aid
the economic
recovery for margate contributing to the
delivery of the margate town deal
and the leveling up agenda delivery of
this capital project will lead to
reduced repairs
bills due to water ingress to the
structure and mitigating asbestos
containing material management
representing potential revenue savings
for the council
i therefore propose the recommendation
in the report
thank you councillor douglas i'll second
that any discussion members
not seeing any discussion in that case
um is the
members minded to agree the
recommendation any dissent
everyone's agreed thank you so that's
agreed
thank you councillor dartmouth moving on
to item
five which is statement of community
involvement
review and public consultation and
that's me
find the appropriate document
so um the statement of community
involvement
the sci is a statutory requirement which
sets out how the council will consult on
planning policy issues
planning applications and neighborhood
plans the sci was originally adopted by
the council in 2007
and reviewed and updated sci was adopted
by council in 2012.
it's considered appropriate that the sci
should be reviewed now in line with the
forthcoming local plan review and update
and to reflect changes in methods of
communication and engagement
there's also a requirement under the
town and county
country planning regulations the scis
are reviewed every five years
um the changes to the sti review are set
out of paragraph 2.2 in the report the
two key changes
are increased recognition of more recent
changes in the use of social media
and seeking to ensure that the sci
reflects these and the flexibility to
deal with situations such as kobit 19
and potential administrative charging
for long and complex submissions
relating to consultation documents
where those submissions are not made
directly into the consultation system
but have to be processed by officers
this can be a time-consuming process
which can cause delayed local plan
progression
however based on previous experience
it's anticipated that the vast majority
of representations
would not be affected by administrative
charges and certainly i'd be concerned
if they were affected by administrative
charges
i think we're talking about uh very
unusual
and time-consuming contributions here
we're not in any way setting up an
obstacle to people
to have their say it's proposed that the
council will carry out a six-week public
consultation on the revised sei
responses to that consultation will be
considered and any appropriate
amendments made it will then be reported
to cabinet
and to full council for adoption so i
move the recommendation
in the report is there a second place
yeah i'll second that chair
thank you that seconded by councillor
album any discussion members
no okay we'll have further opportunity
to talk about this in future
should people wish to um so is that
agreed members
you're not hearing any objections so
that's agreed
so we move on to item six which is your
leisure
get the right document open and that's
me again
so um obviously your leisure has been
affected by
the kovid 19 pandemic as many other
businesses and organizations across that
and across the country have
particularly in the leisure and
entertainment industry
we're bringing this report now because
we have a concern that if the council
doesn't act
uh we could be faced with the prospect
of some important local services
having to cease operation and this in
turn could have far-reaching long-term
effects
given the health inequalities we already
see within our district
if your leisure were to go out of
business there will be significant
financial implications for the council
and we can't avoid those whether we were
to take the services in-house
we were able to identify an alternative
provider or we simply allow the services
to cease because
certainly i think the majority of their
services if not all of their services
are not statutory
but they are very desirable so there is
no risk-free option for the council
we do welcome and acknowledge the recent
government financial support to the
leisure sector
um and indeed your leisure have
benefited from a number of the
initiatives introduced by the government
since last march but because of its
nature
um as an independent organization
the council isn't able to obtain
compensation for
uh lost revenue in the way that it came
from services that it delivers directly
and the latest financial support doesn't
take account of the losses before
december the 2nd 2020
and clearly they've been in a difficult
financial position since march
indeed your legends facilities and
services were all required to close last
march
and at that point their customer income
ceased and while some services have
reopened since um and indeed closed
again since
customer confidence remains low and
there is significant uncertainty still
around when the latest national
restrictions will lift
particularly as they affect your leisure
so what i can say
is that council officers and i've worked
closely with your leisure throughout the
pandemic to understand the changes
the challenges that they've been facing
i personally
i've got confidence in the management's
approach one of the
last things that happened before the
lockdown actually was that councillor
whitehead and i
spent the morning um going around the
the two leisure centres
with kevin fordham um and um
you know i i can only say that we were
very impressed with what we saw so
um we do understand that this is uh
the situation that your leisure finds
itself in is caused by
the issue which is affecting everything
else it's not because of anything
they've done
wrong and there's no suggestion that
they were in trouble
aside from the pandemic i think that the
council needs to show its support for
this
this thing organization we need to help
protect the jobs of the people who are
employed there many of whom are our
residents
protect the services that we provide for
our residents
and mitigate any risk to the council and
i think that this
proposal in the report the
recommendations in the report do that
so i move the recommendations in the
report as a seconder please
a competition for secondly i think has
the duck was probably one thank you
um okay and i'm gonna call in councillor
pugh who wants to speak on this item
thank you leader yes um i mean i won't i
won't go over
stuff that we've already discussed we
had quite an extensive members briefing
earlier this week
um so i'd say that all members are quite
aware of
of um of why we need to provide support
to your leisure and i think it's right
that we're doing so
um however um particularly in in this
report it's listed that
you know this is giving permission uh to
yourself
and to the officer um to make a decision
on this loan
um i suppose my question is really is
where will this end
and i understand that you know it's
quite an open-ended question
but particularly with the council's
finances to be in the way they are
um and of course everyone is struggling
at the moment uh not least residents
um and an uptick in an increase in
council tax
payments i'm sure uh won't help them
but surely we can't be flogging a dead
horse forever and
you know the council's own financial
position needs to be taken into
consideration so
you know perhaps you as leader may be
able to tell me or not at this moment
but you know where will this end where
will it be that the council will decide
rather than just keep handing over money
um that we will need ourselves to walk
away
well councillor pugh what i would say in
response to that is that what's proposed
is a loan
um and clearly a loan is repayable and
it's a loan at the market rate so this
isn't just a question of the council
handing over money i do accept that
within the current context the are risks
attached to that loan
but nevertheless it is alone and we have
to measure that against the liabilities
to which the council could be exposed if
your leisure goes out of business and as
i think as outlined in the report they
are quite considerable
in response to the question of uh where
it ends
i suppose i could equally well ask that
question to boris johnson
because if we accept that the the
problem is driven
entirely by the pandemic and i think we
do accept that across the council
um the prime minister's unable to say
when the pandemic's going to end he's
given us some uh
some hopeful dates um as he has in the
past and i hope this time he's going to
be rather more accurate than he has been
in the past but it's a difficult
difficult question to answer i'll give
the chief executive the opportunity to
make any comments you might want to make
in response to your intervention
uh thank you leader no just to reiterate
i think it's
quite clear from the report that this is
not really
a situation that any of us wanted to
find ourselves in including your leisure
i think it is critical
that we support them at this time with
this
strategy this financial strategy and i
think the leaders made it very clear
at the end of the day much as um
we do need to take into consideration
the council's financial position
and the uh and the risks associated with
ongoing support for your leisure but it
has to be balanced against risks
that are very clear in the report that
tdc faces anyway there's no easy option
here
and there's no risk-free option and i
think on balance our view is
uh and rightly uh that this is the the
best approach and at the end of the day
as a matter of principle i think it's
important the council continues to
support
community services because we will come
to an end uh in respect of this pandemic
at some point
and i think when the restrictions on
trading cease
these are some of the community services
that are going to be really
important going forward so i think this
is absolutely the right approach but
we have said in the report and again i
think that's
absolutely right that we will review the
position
uh every three months so we will keep
that
uh position under review and
uh as with all of these things if if any
other decisions need to be made then we
will consult
uh with members talk to members about
that and
and review the strategy accordingly
thank you
thank you and and i'd just probably like
to add that um throughout the last 10
months
and as the the situation with your
leisure has evolved
we have them kept their two local mps
very closely
informed and asked them to lobby
government around the funding and i
think they've been supportive
of that i'd like to say that and i know
that craig mckinley in particular
has spoken to your leisure and looked at
their financial position
and is able to take a view on it so i'm
sure that um
if the council was acting unreasonably
then then he would be well placed
to to assist you in pointing that out i
don't speak for him but i do say
you know he's been very closely involved
in the discussions that we've had
okay uh members of the cabinet any
further comment on this item
no and as councillor pugh said we did
discuss it at some length uh in a
member's briefing on tuesday
i think that was appropriate i think
it's also appropriate that this report
i mean obviously there are decisions in
it which do need to come into the public
domain but i think it's appropriate this
report
was shared publicly um we brought
brought into the public domain some
quite
um significant financial information
which could be uncomfortable for your
leisure
um and we wanted to be as transparent as
we could
and also to make clear that we are
standing behind this
to fail and organization to our
residents and indeed the jobs
of the people who work for your leisure
so members unless that's um unless i
hear any objections i'm going to take
that the recommendations has agreed
thank you so that's agreed that
concludes the business for tonight's
meeting
um i declare the meeting closed at 5 49
thanks to everyone who's participated in
snow's watching from home
the live stream of the meeting will now
end and thank you to members and
officers
for their time good night
cheers